- Hey.
- Hi.
I see braids.
- I'm gonna fly on a plane
with my two-and-a-half-year-old daughter
to Virginia without my wife.
Flynn, we're going on
an airplane tomorrow.
- [Flynn] Huh?
- We had a trip planned
to go to Austin, Texas,
one last trip before our
second child arrives,
but my grandmother passed away
and I needed to go to
Virginia to be with my family.
Do you think I'll be fine, Kate?
Traveling with Flynn alone on an airplane?
- I do think it's a lot.
- Kate's gonna stay in California
and we're gonna meet up in Austin, Texas,
for Mother's Day.
This might be a disaster.
(crying)
Flynn, we're gonna see Mom in Texas.
Flynn could stay with Kate,
but I really want Flynn to see my mom
and dad and brothers and sisters.
I'm Filipino, and I really want Flynn
to grow up proud to be Filipino.
(bright music)
- [Announcer] A-31 through 60, gates--
- Alright, made it to the airport.
Got the car seat and the diaper bag
in one big, old bag on my back.
Flynn seems a little sad.
As a kid I was a mama's boy,
so I totally sympathize with Flynn.
(bright music)
(Flynn babbling)
While the plane is
reaching cruising altitude,
we're not allowed to use the seat tray,
so I kind of hacked together this way
to hold the iPad up.
But now Flynn doesn't wanna
sit in the car seat anymore.
Luckily Flynn is taking a nap.
It's a few hours past her normal nap time,
but she's napping.
When the plane lands, she's excited.
- We made it to Baltimore.
Now, we gotta get to Norfolk
and gotta say, the car
seat was an accident.
Found an errant smart cart.
(Flynn babbling)
Got some fries for Flynn.
We gate check the car seat,
and it's a lot less stressful
getting Flynn onto the plane
without having to lug around the car seat.
Don't pick your nose.
We're here in Norfolk.
Say hi to Auntie Maya.
Can you give her a hug?
- Hi, Flynn!
- You scared?
Now, Flynn is pretty shy around my dad.
What is it?
We call him Lolo.
Flynn only gets to see my
parents maybe once a year,
so she doesn't really know them that well.
Are you happy to see Auntie Maya?
- Hi, Flynn.
(Flynn laughs)
- You're really happy, very happy.
It's 10:30 in Norfolk, east coast time,
which is 7:30 California time,
so Flynn woke up right on time,
even though you went to bed a little late.
You hungry?
What do you wanna get?
- Bear!
- You can't eat a bear!
The memorial for my grandma
isn't until tomorrow,
but I want to see my
family as much as possible
the few days that we're here.
We're gonna go see Uncle John.
- Uncle John.
- Yeah, my brother.
- Hey!
- Uncle John!
- No.
(soft music)
- Who's that?
- Hey!
I'm so glad you could
come, hello, who's that?
(talking in foreign language)
- So, I called up my mom two weeks ago
to wish her a happy birthday,
and it was that day that I found out
that my grandma was on her deathbed.
My mom was staying beside her all night,
Just to be around, in case she passed.
So, everyone's coming over
to where Flynn and I
are staying for dinner,
and Flynn's cousins and my older brother
are there and they get to hang out.
- Hey!
- Hi, uncle Mark
Flynn's pretty shy around
her cousins at first,
- You can't just grab him
with his hand like that.
- But it doesn't take her long
to hold her hands and have fun.
(children talking)
Pretty soon, a lot of
my family comes over,
including my younger sister Anna,
who I haven't seen in a while,
(children yelling)
It's definitely crowded and it reminds me
a lot of growing up.
(family talking loudly)
We weren't surrounded by a
large Filipino community,
so my family were the
Filipinos that I knew.
As a kid, being of a different culture,
it could be lonely, it can be kinda scary
when people become hostile.
So, I always felt safe around
my family and you know,
I want Flynn to have that same comfort.
I wish we could do this more often.
You're kind of tossing and turning,
but you got to sleep.
- Cousins!
Cousins!
- You want to see your cousins?
- Yeah!
- The whole trip started
out pretty stressful,
but I've adapted, Flynn's has adapted,
We both miss Kate, but you know,
we're having a pretty good time.
You're doing it!
Today's my grandmother's memorial,
and Flynn gets to hang out
with her cousins some more.
♪ Ring around the rosie ♪
- My grandma used to call my siblings
and I her little branches.
♪ Ashes, ashes, we all fall down ♪
- And I guess Flynn is, you
know, an extension of that.
My grandma, my grandpa used
to play music together.
Flynn gets to experience, you know,
us being musical together
and having a good time.
Giving her that exposure
to the Filipino side
of my family is really important to me.
I think I'm finally
able to process the fact
that my grandma's not
in this world anymore.
(somber music)
It's Mother's Day and
my brothers and sisters,
and my mom and dad and Flynn's cousins
get to come with use to
the airport to send us off.
I'm glad I got to tell my
mom happy Mother's Day.
It does feel different, you
know, with my grandma gone.
Like, my mom's the new matriarch.
I've had a lot of fun
with just Flynn and I.
I'm so happy that Flynn got
to hang out with my family.
She's gonna miss her cousins a lot.
But, she also misses
Kate a lot and I do, too.
So, that's gonna be really
awesome to see Kate,
and wish her a happy Mother's Day.
- Mom!
- [Kate] Yay!
- [Dad] Happy Mother's Day!
- I'm excited to see
you, Flynn, I missed you.
- Missed you.
(somber music)